[Musik]
einsatz für die polizei gut 260.000
polizistinnen und polizisten sind
bundesweit immer dann im einsatz
wenn gefahr droht
und jeder einsatz beginnt mit dem notruf
eines einzelnen polizeinotruf übernahme
noch mal
jeden tag gehen hier bis zu 1500 notrufe
bei der polizei in münchen halten wir
sind hier in der einsatzzentrale und von
hier aus wird jeder einsatz der polizei
koordiniert und das einsatzspektrum der
polizei ist breit vom einfachen
ehestreit bis zum wahnsinnigen
messerstecher sein ricken hat die
polizei in hamburg begleitet
mit blaulicht durch den hamburger
austria rast und marc pauliks haben es
eilig ein mann soll seine frau schlagen
sich in gewalt da kommt es auf sekunden
an
wir wollen niemanden gefährden deswegen
tasten wir uns jetzt bei rot auch
vorsichtig in die kreuzung und schauen
dass niemand gefährdet wird recht steht
sie sagt ja dass der mann immer wieder
auf sie zugehen will
und das wollen wir natürlich
schnellstmöglich unterbinden dass sie
weiterhin opfer von gewalt wird ein
anderer streifenwagen ist vor den beiden
da der handfeste streit in der
reihenhaussiedlung ist fürs erste vorbei
als markt pauliks und adrian rast
ankommen steht die frau vor der tür
verletzt alles gut
haben sie angerufen
ein bild machen wollen verletzungen sind
nicht mal ein jahr zusammen haben jetzt
ein kind bekommen vor zwei wochen haben
sich jetzt über diese sachen so ich hab
grad ein kind bekomme ich kann keine
hausarbeit machen er sollte die
hausarbeit machen so dass man in streit
geraten erst gestern schon hochgefahren
ist heute eskaliert die situation ist
auch immer sehr unangenehm weil man
natürlich die tiefste privatsphäre
eindringt und auch immer als unbeteiligt
natürlich schwer sagen kann was stimmt
was stimmt nicht vor ort stellt sich
überraschend heraus der mann wird per
haftbefehl gesucht er hat 1000 euro
strafe nicht gezahlt und kommt in
untersuchungshaft
der häusliche streit ist damit vorläufig
beendet adrian rast und marc pauliks
sind schon beim nächsten auftrag ein
betrunkener mann weigert sich das
einkaufszentrum zu verlassen
die beamten erteilen ein platzverbot
immer an dicht mann er war komplett
ruiniert einige tote trug die
unterwäsche über der oberbekleidung und
sagen wir mal so es gibt nichts was es
nicht gibt was bin ich erleben würden
das hätte auf jeden fall schon eine
reinigung des funkstreifenwagens
erfordert zwischendurch helfen die
polizeikommissare an der wache
der betrunkene mann ist aus einer
spielhalle rausgeschlagen die kollegen
schauen nur ganz kurz abwehren ausweise
oder so finden bei ihnen darum geht's ja
so macht der streifenwagen auf meine
freunde ja das wollen
das wollen wir auch bleiben so wir haben
dieses jahr genau das machen ja okay
jetzt mal ein bisschen weg das wird
langsam ein bisschen er kommt in die
ausnüchterungszelle
mal wieder damals war normal also er war
ja auch schon ein paar mal hier
wir kennen ihn schon es geht auch ganz
anders also dass wir die wirklich an
allen vieren hier eintragen müssen und
diese für leib und leben wären quasi
dann war das schon ein bisschen anders
aber das war jetzt eigentlich noch
standard
dann wird es hektisch ein mann soll mit
einem messer in der hand herumlaufen
gleich mehrere andere vermelden adrian
rast und marc pauliks sind als erste
frau ein messer als waffe ist extrem
gefährlich niemand weiß was der mann vor
hat plötzlich tauchte direkt vor dem
streifen mag pauliks war früher in einer
spezialeinheit er hat schwere jungs
festgenommen solche situationen auf
einer wiener straße erlebt er jetzt nur
noch selten alle hier sind angespannt
messer liegt da was genau der mann vor
hatte niemand weiß es wir sind rum
gekommen dass er auf der strasse
gegangen wir wohnen von dem passanten
angesprochen dass er es ist wir haben
ihn angesprochen her hat eine diskussion
mit rusty angefangen hab ich hier
verfasst haben jetzt messer sand
geschluckt alles gutgegangen keiner
musste schießen hochbrisante natürlich
auch für uns wenn es heißt
messerstecherei und daher läuft wir vor
uns zehn meter mit messer über die
straße bei der ts ansprache mit
vorgehaltener pistole ob da nicht
reagiert bisher kollege angegriffen hat
mit einzubringen gebracht also gerade
mit dem messer ist halt hochgesand und
hier gab genug anrufer die sich gemeldet
haben und gesagt haben das kann ja nicht
wahr sein
wir prüfen jetzt in der dienststelle was
los ist ja und jetzt nach den
vorkommnissen der letzten tage ist das
natürlich die ganze bevölkerung ist ein
bisschen vielleicht noch ein bisschen
verunsichert wie oft diesmal in den
nachrichten verletzungen besser da und
wie schnell und mit messer arbeiten kann
das wird uns gezeigt und da kann man
teilweise auch gar nicht reagieren
deswegen hält man auch mit dem
entsprechenden abstand
das ist natürlich auch für uns eine
belastende situation und extrem unter
spannung
wenn man mit dem messer wollte so sagte
im streifenwagen anhänger der terror
miliz es töten die habe ihm angeblich
seine töchter weggenommen mehr bekomme
die beamten nicht aus ihm heraus adrian
rast und marc pauliks waren wohl
rechtzeitig daran hängt ob das kann ich
ganz gute verknüpfen also das hat mich
jetzt nicht aus der bahn geworfen also
ich hab mich jetzt nicht irgendwie in
einer großen gefahr gefühle oder so hat
eigentlich ein ganz gutes gefühl in
letzter zeit anscheinend kam der mann
aus norwegen nach deutschland er selbst
behauptete dort polizist zu sein die
kriminalpolizei übernimmt für adrian
raste und marc pauliks geht diese
schicht bei zu ende
dienstbeginn dagegen für die
autobahnpolizei und auf der autobahn
herrschen eigene gesetze glauben
zumindest viele autofahrer damit es
nicht wie im wilden westen aussieht
kommen die chefs des asphalts zum
einsatz
die a 7 zwischen kiel und hamburg die
polizistin tanja potratz und thomas
arndt patroullieren mit ihrer mobilen
radarfalle ihr ziel verkehrsrowdys von
der straße holen
der erste kandidat ein rasen dabei kam
die beamten werden erstmal ausgebremst
das macht sich
der dienst mercedes ist mit fast 300 ps
ausgestattet genug um dem raser zu
folgen
doch wieder kommt ihnen ein langsameres
auto in die quere
[Musik]
die polizisten haben keine chance
gerade von rechts eine uns vor vor die
nase gefahren dass wir eben halt den
anschluss nicht halten konnten er ist
mit wesentlich überhöhter
geschwindigkeit hier in den baustellen
trichter eingefahren
tanja und thomas riskieren nicht ihre
gesundheit und lassen den biker ziehen
ärgerlich doch es dauert nicht lange bis
der nächste fahrer über die stränge
schlägt
freie fahrt hier nochmal wiederholt 120
aufgestellt die beamten haben genug
gesehen zeit den rüpel von der straße zu
holen
gar nicht so einfach
dann schon eher ist auf 2 x relativ
kurzfristig aufgefahren
ich weiß aber schon aufmerksam
endlich der fahrer hat verstanden was
die beamten wollen 70 euro und ein punkt
sind ihm sicher
über 150 sind sie gefahren dass ein
videowagen wenn das ganze gefilmt es
besteht die möglichkeit wenn sie wollen
können sie sich den film gern mit
unserem interesse
fehlanzeige doch die reiserei dass man
es war alles andere als harmlos
die gefahr ist dass man wenn man jetzt
die geschwindigkeit hält in diesem
bereich nicht unbedingt damit rechnen
dass eine mit 40 km/h mehr als
wasserlaufes dort an ihm vorbeifährt
es gibt auch verkehrsteilnehmer die
nicht jeden tag auf der autobahn sind
ich sag mal alte herrschaften die mit 70
jahren ein zweimal im monat im jahr auf
der autobahn fahren die rechnung nicht
unbedingt damit dass einer jetzt hier 40
jahren also schnell fest dass wir würden
andere leute niemals machen
trotzdem hofft der handwerker dass die
beamten ein auge zudrücken und kommen
nur zwölf kann sich dann beschäftigen
aber natürlich besser wenn du da kann es
helfen wenn ihr jetzt eine seine
zwölfjährige tochter zu hause hat das
ist wahr
alles liebe und schön und als
väterlicher 60 hätte ich auch zu
verstehen aber für uns gibt es da eben
halt kein handlungsspielraum über
handeln denen gleich und wenn einer aus
dem grunde 160 fährt ist genauso schlimm
für uns aus einem anderen vielleicht
will beginnen
fälle wie diese erleben die
verkehrspolizisten häufig auf den
autobahnen in schleswig-holstein
material mitgebracht aus dem vergangenen
monat
tanja potratz zeigt eine heikle szene
mit einem geländewagen die fahrerin gibt
kräftig gas
120 im bereich kurz vor hamburg wo auch
wirklich viel verkehr ist und da ist
einfach so ungebremst durch gewalt sieht
man hier um 10 km/h noch einmal die
schnelle aufgestellt und da stört man
sich gar nicht dran
da wird das schlichtweg einfach total
ignoriert also das war schon ziemlich
geschwindigkeitsüberschreitung ihren
führerschein ist die fahrerin los
obendrein wird es teuer
akzeptiert haben und da haben wir ihn
vom vorsatz ausgegangen weil wir immer
wieder uns auch erzählt haben dass sie
es eilig haben und deswegen wird die
geld muss in diesem fall verdoppelt also
da sind sich 440 euro zone 880 euro
die haben da auch die fahrerin zu kommen
die beamten brechen wieder auf zur jagd
werden aber erneut ausgebremst dieses
mal durch einen verkehrsunfall
das team übernimmt bis ein streifenwagen
da ist denn es herrscht dichter verkehr
und die unfallstelle ist noch
ungesichert thomas arndt geht auf
spurensuche
[Musik]
ich habe nicht gesehen dass sie stetig
habe gebremst haben wenn ich ihn rauf
gerutscht das auto ist natürlich schaut
das ist scheiße
die unfallursache scheint für die
polizisten klar
doch plötzlich klagt eine fahrerin über
schmerzen spüren ist das meistens
schlimmer wird die beamten gehen auf
nummer sicher und rufen einen
krankenwagen
thomas übergibt an die kollegen dann
geht es weiter die dame ist verletzt
worden für die heber krankenhaus und wir
haben die kollegen die orts kollegen
trotz als jetzt den kollegen hier bei
der unfallaufnahme beziehungsweise auf
den absperrmaßnahmen unterstützt weil
das auch vom blöder punkt hier ist
unheimlich viel verkehr ist ampelanlagen
an autobahnauffahrten insofern war das
ganz glücklich fühlen auch dass wir in
diesem moment ihr vorbeikommen zurück
auf die a 7 die beamten entdecken wieder
ein fahrer der zu schnell unterwegs ist
die polizistin befürchtet dass der
fahrer auch in gefährlichen
baustellenbereich auf dem gaspedal
bleibt und behält recht
80 km h zulässig immer noch wesentlich
zu schnell unterwegs
über 120 in der 80er zone
das wird teuer den polizisten klingen
jetzt schon faule ausreden in den ohren
doch nur ganz selten kommen raser
ungeschoren davon
das hat der schwangere frau auf
beifahrer sind die ins krankenhaus
musste da haben wir allerdings sind aber
auch vor ort die fahrt untersagt und
haben einen rettungswagen gerufen
dieses argument zieht hier schon mal
nicht der fahrer ist sich dennoch keiner
schuld bewusst die anderen seien
verantwortlich für sein verhalten
mit schwimmen ist für mich wenn
fahrzeuge fahren die genauso schnell
gefahren sind und das ist nun deutlich
auf dem video waren zu sehen dass es
nicht so war
das hören wir auch echt auf werden wir
die verkehrsteilnehmer anhalten
die beamten kennen kein pardon auch wenn
den fahrer die strafe besonders hart
trifft er ist beruflich auf seinen
führerschein angewiesen
daher wird wahrscheinlich im bereich
eines fahrverbotes landen werden wir
nachher geschwindigkeit und mehr als
41.000 auswerten sind einen monat
fahrverbot 160 euro werkstatt 30 euro
verwaltungsgebühren
der mann bekommt bald post von der
bußgeldstelle wie etwa 70.000 andere
fahrer jährlich in schleswig-holstein
damit die zahl der verkehrssünder sinkt
macht sich das team potratz und arndt
weiter auf raser jagt die autobahn a3
bei passau im grenzgebiet zu österreich
wir begleiten zwei schleierfahnder der
bayerischen polizei rund um die uhr sind
sie und ihre kollegen in zivilfahrzeugen
auf streife diesmal haben sie einen
kleintransporter aus moldawien im visier
[Applaus]
dabei ist oder führerschein austrosoft
formen bayern setzt hiermit seine pläne
um die eigene grenzpolizei ist der
anfang wir bekämpfen die
drogenkriminalität die urkunden
kriminalität natürlich auch die
schleuserkriminalität wobei man ja auch
sagen muss dass die zahl der schließungs
auf gerüchte zurück gegangen ist
die bayerische grenzpolizei gab es schon
einmal
von 1945 bis 1998 bis zur öffnung des
schengen raums dann gab die bayerische
grenzpolizei ihre befugnisse an die
bundespolizei nun will bayern sein
grenzgebiet auch wieder selbst
kontrollieren bundespolizei leistet gute
arbeit hat aber selbst in den letzten
jahren immer wieder gesagt dass sie für
bestimmte zusätzliche maßnahmen zu wenig
leute hat und hier wollen wir ein
eigenes zeichen als freistaat bayern
setzen künftig sollen die bayerischen
grenzpolizisten auch eigenständige
grenzkontrollen durchführen können
gesetzlich neu geregelt ist das aber
noch nicht
zurzeit liegt die hoheit solcher
kontrollen wie zb hier am
autobahnübergang bei freilassing
ausschließlich bei der bundespolizei
willkommen ist eine personelle
unterstützung klar geregelt sein muss
aber dass das unter die befugnisse der
bundespolizei fällt und die
bundespolizei das sagen in diesem
einsatz bereichert schon jetzt arbeiten
bundespolizisten bei den grenzkontrollen
seite an seite mit bayerischen kollegen
eine hundertschaft der bayerischen
bereitschaftspolizei unterstützt die
bundesbeamten an den drei permanenten
autobahn kontrollpunkten diese sind seit
herbst 2015 an den grenzübergängen
pocking freilassing und kiefersfelden
der rest der über 800 kilometer langen
deutsch österreichischen grenze wird nur
sporadisch kontrolliert genau hier will
bayern jetzt nachrüsten mit insgesamt
1000 eigenen grenzpolizisten werden auch
die grenzpolizeiinspektion zum beispiel
mit drohnen ausstatten mit
entsprechenden kameras so dass sie auch
aus der luft den grenznahen bereich
überwachen können
mit der bayerischen grenzpolizei setzt
der freistaat einen punkt aus seinem
asyl planum bayern macht klar es geht
seinen eigenen weg notfalls auch alleine
auf verbrecherjagd in münchen gehen
polizeioberkommissar leonard winkler und
polizeiobermeisterin patricia wir dürfen
ihre schicht begleiten
der erste einsatz
[Musik]
gaffer behindern rettungskräfte bei
einer reanimation
als die streife eintrifft was sind die
schaulustigen bereits weg die
rettungskräfte kämpfen um das überleben
einer radfahrerin sie hatten probleme
angeblich mit gaffern eigentlich ein
warum die feuerwehr dann letztendlich
jeder dass eine dame aufgrund eines
schwächeanfalls vom fahrrad gefallen ist
irgendwo bei der animationstechnik wurde
so wie das jetzt bekommen sie wird ja
auch gerade in den rettungswagen
verbrachte gegen den gaffern die
angeblich sich eingemischt haben kannst
du mir dazu geholt worden
sobald wir ein getroffen haben wir
wirklich probleme wir haben uns dann
noch um die schülerin gekümmert die die
dame auf gefunden hat und die paar
minuten verstanden worden
die patientin kommt ins krankenhaus und
die schicht geht weiter haben sie ein
auffälliges fahrzeug mal erkennt sie ja
direkt als polizei kriegen sie das auch
mit dass die autofahrer links und rechts
neben ihnen immer bisschen nervöser
werden wenn sie neben anhalten analyse
in dem sinne würde kann ich sagen er
brauche immer sehr faszinierende
unterschied zwischen dienstlicher und
privater fahrten privat 7 sehr viele
verkehrsverstöße und kaum ist man im
dienst pkw unterwegs sind natürlich alle
plötzlich kreuzfahrt wenn jemand
angehalten werden möchte deshalb auch
nur nachvollziehbar zu den eigenschaften
eines polizisten was würden sie ihm
sagen muss ein polizist unbedingt können
ich glaube es gibt nicht die eine
eigenschaft die der polizeibeamte
braucht sondern viele positive
eigenschaften die ihr vereinen muss also
wissen
nicht nur irgendwie die böse polizei die
strafverfolgung betreibt wir sind
genauso ansprechpartner und helfer für
diejenigen die eben gerade hilfe
brauchen
wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß dann
geht man den notruf und dann kommt
jemand im idealfall team helfen kann und
wissen eben wie es ist egal ob essawi
auffahrunfall ist oder zb den abstürze
als erstes kommt die polizei und muss
sich darum kümmern und irgendwie dieses
problem diesen klar und einfach drunter
aufgaben halte mich da nicht mal einer
anhalten
du musst sehr viel nachwuchs die
kriminalitätsstatistik gesagt hat dass
die zahlen rückläufig sind merken sie
das denn auch dass sie jetzt weniger
einsätze haben dass die schichten
ruhiger werden
ich persönlich würde sagen nein das
liegt aber vielleicht weniger daran als
daran dass die polizei insgesamt einfach
für immer mehr leute zu schicken ist
wenn natürlich neue um gebiete gibt und
ganz viel gebaut wird haben wir
natürlich auch dementsprechend mehr
einsätze weil einfach mehr leute in
unseren dienst bereich wohnen die
einsätze produzieren sage ich mal
oder wie sie zu lösen
natürlich der innenminister hat ja
ghs vorgestellt es gibt glaube ich immer
auch einen großen schwund in große
differenz zwischen objektiven und
subjektiven sicherheitsgefühl
und die zahlen sagen er ist rückläufig
dennoch wird man wahrscheinlich wenn man
auf der straße
die umfrage macht wird dann jeder
bestätigen ja ja die welt ist seit 1980
wesentlich unsicherer geworden und jeden
tag werden 17 kinder von der schule weg
gepflückt und entführt und so weiter und
so fort
aber denen es eben nicht so der mensch
ist einfach sehr subjektiv traurig und
das ist bei uns genau so wenn man jetzt
denkt er heute ist er nicht so viel los
war es ist sonntagnachmittag da werden
die leute wahrscheinlich schönen
biergarten sitzen und die ruhe haben
wollen ist dann plötzlich die hölle los
und umgekehrt freitag nach die meistens
naturgemäß etwas mehr los ist es dann
plötzlich kein einziger einmal leicht
kann man doch nicht so vorhersehen und
könnten erst dann würden wir glaube ich
wesentlich anders noch mal planen hier
stehen die objektiven zahlen gegen das
subjektive empfinden reale sicherheit
mehr sucht gefühlter sicherheit und auch
bei den wohnungseinbrüchen sagt die
statistik dass die zahlen rückläufig
sind ein grund dafür sind spezielle
sonderkommission serien begleitet die
soko kassel in hamburg sie haben wieder
zugeschlagen einbrecher in hamburg die
täter haben zunächst ein garagenfenster
aufgebrochen um an eine leiter und eine
säge zu gelangen
hauptkommissar warnecke von der soko
kassel untersucht den tatort mit leiter
und säge sind sie auf der rückseite des
hauses dann übers dach eingestiegen
immer wieder versuchen einbrecher so
mögliche alarmanlagen im erdgeschoss zu
umgehen dass sie beim einstieg durchs
dach hier allerdings genau bei einer ab
seite im schlafzimmer gelandet sind die
von außen gar nicht einsehbar ist macht
den erfahrenen ermittler nachdenklich
das ist auf jeden fall eine sehr
ungewöhnliche geschichte zweifellos
alleine wieder hereingekommen sind
ob tatsächlich ist in die täter wissen
schon vorher auch vorher insider wissen
kann man noch nicht beurteilen da war
ich schon ein bisschen ab insofern schon
ein interessanter fall die geschädigte
möchte nicht erkannt werden die ältere
dame war während des einbruchs beim
bridge hier ist das alles schrecklich
peinlich
wir stellen wurden ihr bargeld und
schmuck im wert von mehr als 6000 euro
sie hat bereits eine liste mit den
gestohlenen dingen erstellt das kann
helfen falls die leute wieder auftaucht
seit gut einem jahr gibt es in hamburg
die soko kassel die polizei versucht so
die dramatisch angestiegenen
einbruchszahlen in den griff zu bekommen
mit erfolg wie sich auf der täglichen
lagebesprechung zeigt seitdem es die
soko gibt ist die zahl der einbrüche um
knapp zehn prozent zurückgegangen
gleichzeitig hat sich die
aufklärungsquote auf gut 12 prozent fast
verdoppelt zum konzept der einbruch
sonderkommission gehören immer wieder
verkehrskontrollen damit will die
polizei die täter verunsichern und
vertreiben einbruch ist ein florierender
zweig des organisierten verbrechens
geworden es gibt straff organisierte
banden die sich mit einbrüchen
finanzieren und von land zu land reisen
[Musik]
verschiedene wohnung vor neuen einbruch
sie sagen so klar muss man das sagen
die dunkle jahreszeit ist die haupt
einbruchszeit und die erkenntnisse der
soko kassel gehen eindeutig dahin dass
wir uns sehr darauf fokussieren müssen
auf den reisenden serieneinbrecher aus
osteuropa südosteuropa teilweise auch
aus chile und das ist jetzt hier unser
ansatz anfang des jahres ein volltreffer
bei einer der vielen verkehrskontrolle
stoppten die polizisten einen wagen aus
bulgarien
die drei insassen offenbar einbrecher
die ermittler entdecken typisches
einbruchswerkzeug sogar einen stein zum
scheiben einwerfen und eine pistole
haben sie dabei auch diebesgut wird
sichergestellt
soko chefin alexandra klein weiß ohne
die hilfe der bevölkerung kann sie die
einbruchswelle nicht stoppen die
ermittlerin wünscht sich von den bürgern
dass sie aufmerksam sind dass sie wenn
sie ein entsprechendes bauchgefühl haben
diese hürde 110 anzurufen überspringen
damit sie einfach wissen das ist keine
große hürde auf seiten der polizei
sondern wir wünschen dass sogar dass sie
uns anrufen weil wir eben wissen wenn
der bürger was meldet dann ist das eine
sehr gute beobachtung
eindringlich warnt die polizei vor einer
eskalation im juni 2015 erschießt ein
hausbesitzer einen einbrecher auf
frischer tat ein einzelfall
denn den tätern gelingt es meist zu
verschwinden bevor ihre opfer nach hause
zurückkommen
für ein einbrechertrio aus serbien endet
die flucht vor der polizei im
krankenhaus als die polizei ihr auto
stoppen will rasen sie über diverse rote
ampeln in einer scharfen kurve geraten
sie ins schleudern und rahmen mehrere
parkende wagen ein spektakuläres ende
ihrer einbruchstour nachdem die fast 100
köpfige soko kassel ihre arbeit begonnen
hatte kam es zunächst zum stau bei der
staatsanwaltschaft da wurde inzwischen
nachgerüstet so sollen sich bis anfang
nächsten jahres drei hamburger
staatsanwälte ausschließlich um
einbrüche kümmern denn für entwarnung
ist es noch viel zu früh
auch bei harry schäferling wurde
eingebrochen die täter haben bei ihm
gleich den ganzen tresor aus der wand
gerissen mit mehreren tausend euro
bargeld und wertvollen schmuck
die der soko ermittler erfährt sind die
einbrecher besonders dreist vorgegangen
sie kamen während der gastwirt unten im
erdgeschoss unter seiner wohnung
gearbeitet hat morgens gegen 4 uhr
feierabend bin hier in die wohnung
gekommen
da war die tür nicht mehr so angelegt
und die balkontür war auf und da war mir
klar hier muss einer gewesen sein
auch hier sind die täter oben
eingestiegen die einbruchsspuren an der
balkontür zeigen ein paar kräftige stöße
mit einem schraubenzieher haben gereicht
und sie waren drin wie sie es geschafft
haben auf den balkon zu klettern muss
die polizei noch ermitteln ob kommissar
warnecke sucht nach weiteren spuren im
garten die täter bringen kaum etwas mit
sie nutzen werkzeuge und gartengeräte
wie sie vor ort finden
ob die einbrecher dann hier über das
nachbargrundstück geflohen sind müssen
die weiteren ermittlungen zeigen
im schnitt alle drei minuten wird
irgendwo in deutschland eingebrochen
die täter brauchen meist nur sekunden um
in häuser oder wohnungen einzudringen
und zu rauben was wertvoll ist oder sich
auf dem schwarzmarkt zu geld machen
lässt
die polizei in niedersachsen hat jetzt
eine software entwickelt die mögliche
tatorte vorhersagen sollte nicht die
polizei hat aus der vergangenheit ganz
viele erfahrung um wohnungseinbruchs
diebstähle
diese erfahrung haben wir gesammelt und
haben gesagt mensch wir müssen mal
gucken ob da nicht ähnliche straftaten
wieder passieren es geht vor allem auch
um einbrüche von organisierten banden
die gezielt in bevorzugten stadtteilen
zu schlagen auf basis früherer
straftaten zeigt das programm
schwerpunkte in einem stadtgebiet und
bevorzugte uhrzeiten an
es wird täglich mehrfach aktualisiert
die kollegen in den streifenwagen können
dieses programm auf ihrem tablet über
eine app aufrufen sie fahren dann an den
orten vermehrt kontrollfahrten wo die
wahrscheinlichkeit hoch ist dass ein
einbruch stattfindet
wir sind sicher dass mit der
weiterentwicklung dieser app auch in
zukunft einsatz und ermittlungs
technisch und taktisch das uns weiter
nach vorne bringen wird in einigen
städten niedersachsens wird die
einbrecher app derzeit erprobt noch ist
das projekt in der pilotphase die
vorläufige bilanz sieht vielversprechend
aus meinen die macher man kann jetzt
schon sagen dass hier ein werkzeug schon
mal in den werkzeugkasten der polizei
hinein gelegt wurde als ergänzung der
ohnehin schon bestehenden werkzeuge
es gibt natürlich bei einem solchen
instrument immer wieder auch anpassungen
zu fahren
kritiker befürchten dass sich
brennpunkte durch vermehrte kontrollen
nur verschieben
wir dürfen aber nicht vergessen die
polizei hat auch die verpflichtung den
bürger und sein eigentum zu schützen
das bedeutet wenn die polizei kenntnis
von straftaten hat die gemeinde kurz
bevorstehen
dann bleibt nicht viel anderes übrig als
auch dann eine art verdrängungseffekt
vorzunehmen einfach zum schutz des
bürgers und des eigentums die einbrecher
app soll nach der erprobungsphase in
ganz niedersachsen eingeführt werden
allerdings der eindringliche appell der
polizei
hab und gut sichern dafür sollten auch
haus- und wohnungseigentümer selbst
sagen
haben sie denn schon mal ein einbrecher
auf frischer tat ertappt man hat
natürlich sehr oft verhandlungen zum
beispiel der bürger anruft und meldet
oder etwas gesehen
leider sind dann doch so oft dass sich
diese leute halt schon bemerkbar machen
und sagen was machen sie da oder solche
sachen und die dann natürlich flüchten
bevor die polizei eintrifft
also welchen städten sind da lieber den
einbrecher beobachten die polizei aus
dem hintergrund anrufen so dass man den
schnappen kann ja also sobald man die
offensiv auch ein einfacher zu gehen
weil ich denke und weiß nie wie der
reagiert vielleicht wird er doch
aggressiv oder handgreiflich deswegen
also wenn man die möglichkeit hat und
dann nicht schon mitten im geschehen ist
dann würde ich schon sagen dass es
besser wäre dass man das ganze aus
sicherer entfernung beobachtet und dann
die polizei verständigt um dafür gebürgt
fachleute ran lässt sie sind ja nah dran
an der bevölkerung wie nehmen sie die
stimmung war ging nur der polizei ja ich
denke vor allem
bei älteren herrschaften merkt man sehr
stark dass sie sehr viel respekt vor der
polizei haben
[Musik]
bei jüngeren menschen würde ich sagen
das ist unterschiedlich kann man jetzt
nicht so an irgendwas bestimmten
festmachen
ja manche haben wirklich gar keinen
respekt mehr vor der polizei die da
könnte auch eine person stehen die keine
uniform hat und die würden sich genau so
viel oder so wenig sagen lassen wie von
der polizei
[Musik]
was macht man da ja das kommt darauf an
was man was man in dem moment möchte von
dieser person
es gibt natürlich sagen da muss man dann
einfach durchgreifen deswegen sind wir
auch die polizei es gibt aber vielleicht
auch situationen wo man dann einfach mal
sagen kann ja es gut jetzt schönen tag
noch um und fährt dann wieder weil man
weil die sache damit auch für uns
vielleicht gegessen ist
ich will das jetzt mal so ein bisschen
überspitzt formulieren im grunde können
sie doch nur alles falsch machen
die einen sagen dass übertriebene härte
polizeigewalt
die anderen sagen die polizei ist viel
zu lasch und greift nicht durch würden
sie ihren beruf noch mal machen ihre
ausbildung noch mal beginnen wir als
polizei sind neutral und dass man dann
wenn es nicht jedem recht machen kann
ist er jemand
was zu meckern hat wird auch meckern
egal wie man nur sein wenn wir im
unterricht auch darüber was wir
natürlich immer zwischen den fronten
stehen weil wir einfach mal sind also
dass wir einmal teilweise das feindbild
sind bei einer versammlung lage ist es
das beste beispiel
wir schützen das versammlungsrecht also
ein grundrecht ein menschenrecht und
geraten da natürlich auch meinen den
fokus egal ob von links oder von rechts
oder von wem auch immer weil wir
diejenigen sind die dann die
ordnungsmaßnahmen durchsetzen müssen und
das gefällt natürlich nicht geben und
dann kann man auch feindbild sehen in
der ausbildung werden die beamten auf
solche situationen vorbereitet
zwischen den fronten zu stehen wie auch
im nächsten einsatz
eine frau soll am bahnhof eine person
geschlagen haben
die sind schon abläufe die bei ihnen
durch den kopf gehen mal zum einsatz
oder ist das routine
das ist routine also ich denke mal man
kann sich ungefähr vorstellen dass man
jetzt zu erwarten hat und was man jetzt
machen frist außerdem richtet hier ganz
stark von dem ab was uns über die
einsatzzentrale durchgegeben wurde und
eine eigenschaft die jeder polizist
mitbringen muss zuhören eine verwirrte
frau sondern mit ihrer handtasche
zugeschlagen haben die beschuldigte
erinnert sich an nichts denn die frau
keinen festen wohnsitz hat muss sich
erst mal mit auf die wache kommen über
schuld und unschuld wird später ein
richter entscheiden müssen gesehen das
einsatzspektrum der polizei auf streife
ist vielfältig von der hilfeleistung im
rettungseinsatz
oder bei körperverletzung
eins ist klar ob politiker oder
traumberuf die ausbildung zur polizistin
zum polizisten ist schwierig und ein
sehr langer weg
in brandenburg werden sie dringend
gebraucht neue polizisten viele neue
polizisten hier an der fachhochschule
oranienburg werden sie ausgebildet 850
polizeianwärter für sie ein traumberuf
beim normalen bürojob weiß man halt die
arbeit hat man das und das und das zu
tun
jedoch wenn man jetzt zum beispiel im
wach und wechseldienst ist weiß man nie
was ein wirklich erwartet und hatte so
viel abwechslung drin das ist das was
gerade gar nichts ausmacht bei der
polizei für mich auch die gewissheit
finanziell abgesichert zu sein ist für
viele hier wichtig dazu kommen die
arbeit im team und ein bisschen
nervenkitzel
doch was in der theorie aussieht wie ein
actionfilm kann in der praxis
ernüchternd sein
man wird ja mit auch der unteren
gesellschaft im praktikum konfrontiert
mit mit armut mit alkohol krankheiten
und ja es ist natürlich bilder mit
methoden auch es sind bilder die nicht
jeder unbedingt verkraften kann
die folge 10 bis 15 prozent
abbrecherquote und die wird zunehmend
zum problem denn jahrelang hat
brandenburg kaum polizisten ausgebildet
stattdessen einstellungsstopp
einsparungen jetzt werden sie plötzlich
gebraucht der grund eine veränderte
sicherheitslage
sie geht auch an den studierenden nicht
spurlos vorbei die angst ist auf jeden
fall immer da und ich glaube die wird
auch bleiben und ist auch wichtig dass
man so einen gewissen respekt davor hat
weil der beruf polizist oder polizistin
ist ja nun mal mit einer gewissen -
risiko das man halt doch angegriffen
wird oder dass man halt auch nicht so
glimpflich aus verlage kommt aber darauf
kann man sich einstellen schon beim
auswahlgespräch müssen die bewerber
zeigen dass sie das auch können
350 neue polizeianwärter werden in
diesem jahr gesucht so viele wie zuletzt
für uns ist auch wichtig dass die jungen
menschen die sich für die polizei
bewerben genau mit diesem problem auch
umgehen können dass sie ihnen also
bewusst ist dass diese veränderte
sicherheitslage zum täglichen beruf zu
ihren job gehört
heute werden 90 absolventen
verabschiedet hinter ihnen liegen drei
jahre ausbildung vor ihnen der alltag
als polizist der hat sich verändert doch
auch die polizisten selbst sind heute
anders
zu meiner zeit hat man sich irgendwann
mal für den polizeidienst entschieden
und das heißt halt 40 jahre für den
dienstherrn das ist heute anders
wenn die leute merken das macht keinen
spaß oder es fordert mich nicht heraus
oder es ist mir zu stressig dann
kündigen die auch gehen weg suchen sich
was anderes es ist ein kampf um die
besten köpfe und das obwohl es in diesem
jahr 4500 bewerber gab
nicht alle sind geeignet doch für die
die es geschafft haben ist der
polizeiberuf noch immer ein traumberuf
[Applaus]
wir sind zurück in der einsatzzentrale
der polizei münchen der chef hier ist
polizeidirektor ulrich roth tauschen und
von hier aus werden nicht nur notrufe
koordiniert was ist denn genau hier in
der einsatzzentrale was mit ihr gemacht
wir sorgen dafür dass die polizei zu
ihnen kommt wenn sie den notruf 110
aber es kommt nicht nur die polizei
sondern es kommt die polizei
strukturiert auf den einsatz vorbereitet
und mit dem ziel die gefahrenlage zu
minimieren oder die straftat zu
verfolgen
gibt es denn auch anrufe und situationen
die sie an ihre grenzen gebracht haben
so kommt es auch schon mal vor dass
apple setzt
bei so viel anrufen grundsätzlich ist es
so wir sind mit zehn notruf disponenten
relativ gut ausgestattet
normalerweise arbeiten wir damit
hervorragend des alltags geschehen ab
herausragende lagen wie jetzt
meinetwegen der amok laufen liegt der
einkaufszentrum stößt natürlich dann
auch bei uns irgendwann einmal an
kapazitätsgrenzen so dass dann schon mal
eine bandansage kommen kann
bitte legen sie nicht auf wir bearbeiten
ihr ein anderes macht ist jetzt gehen
wir jeden tag bis zu 1600 anrufe ein
da ist ja jetzt nicht jeder anruf mord
und totschlag da sind hat auch viele
kinkerlitzchen kleinigkeiten dabei ist
ihr eindruck wenn man dann im kita
streit denkt wo mütter die polizei ruft
weil die kinder sich streiten ist ein
bisschen die streitkultur verloren
gegangen in deutschland in sachen king
khalid ist es schon schwierig in der ex
ante sich zu beurteilen ist es ein kind
kelly ziehen
mein lieblingsbeispiel ist die
mitteilung eines nachts weiters im
schlafzimmer in den notruf und zwar hat
uns eine aufgeregte dame mittleren
alters darüber verständigt dass in ihrem
schlafzimmer nachts weiters dass sie
keinem erklären kann dass dieser nacht
weiter für die bedrohung ist und das
mündete letztendlich einen
polizeieinsatz hat jeder erst mal gesagt
warum fährt die polizei zu einem
nachtfalter im schlafzimmer ganz einfach
war ist was man selber fühlt die
mitteilende hatte angst stand im
hausflur und wusste sich nicht anders
zeigen und das ist genau unser job und
dann kommen wir auch mal für nacht
weiter aufwärts polizeilich objektive
nicht gefährlich ist aber subjektiv und
haben damit verhindert dass jemand
hilflos alleingelassen in einem hausflur
steht und das ist unser job
sie haben jetzt ihre angesprochen
nachtfalter auch die polizei hat der
tierische helfer wann kommen denn hunde
oder pferde im einsatz
darüber denken wir die spezifischen
fähigkeiten brauchen hunde ganz klar die
spürnase reichte zeitraum rauschgift und
sprengstoff
und wenn wir diese fähigkeiten brauchen
dann fordern wir die anderen und in
jedem fall brauchen auch die tierischen
helfer der polizei eine ausbildung
die hat es in sich
wenta d'or für ihn ist es der tag der
entscheidung darf der siebenjährige
wallach bleiben und ein richtiges
polizeipferd werden bei der hessischen
reiterstaffel in frankfurt das training
macht aventador heute mit seinen pferde
kumpeln an einem hier orientieren sich
alle camino er ist schon 14 und ein sehr
erfahrenes polizeipferd
ausbildungsleiter für die reiter ist
frank seemann
aber auch die pferde akzeptieren ihn als
obersten chef also wenn ich ein pferd
wäre ich wahrscheinlich in der in der
herde des ranghöchsten ganz klar
winterthur ist erst seit drei monaten
hier seine probezeit musste verlängert
werden denn es ist noch nicht ganz klar
ob er der anspruchsvollen aufgabe
gewachsen ist ein polizeipferd braucht
stählerne nerven das muss täglich geübt
werden
heute wird ein sky dancer eingesetzt
jedes normale reitpferd würde in einer
solchen situation reißaus nehmen also
wir versuchen einfach den fluchtinstinkt
des pferdes so zu minimieren in der
ausbildung das pferde wenn sie dann
optische eindrücke zum ersten mal sehen
dass sie sich in dem moment einfach auf
den reiter verlassen weil zwischen
reiter und pferd so ein
vertrauensverhältnis entstanden das in
der ausbildung dass es dann später wenn
zum erstmal mit sonst geht er dann
konfrontiert wird sagt ach ich erinnere
mich da war was ich vertraue meinem
reiter und wir machen das gemeinsam die
erste prüfung hat aventador bestanden
denn erreicht nur etwas zurück aber er
rastet nicht aus die nächste übung soll
die pferde an fahnen schwenkende fußball
fans gewöhnen aventador muss sich jetzt
zusammenreißen denn er hat ein problem
mit berührungen
vielleicht ist er früher oft geschlagen
worden vor drei monaten noch reagierte
der wallach oft so etwas richtig
aggressiv ich hätte mich niemals mit der
fahne hier hinstellen können und die
fahne auflegen dürfen als er hätte jetzt
in dem moment vielleicht gezielt nach
mehr getreten oder wenn er spürt dass an
die beine gut oder auf die gruppe wenn
er hier berührt wird
dann wäre er sofort massiv geworden
jetzt habe ich so viel vertrauen
und zu ihm dass ich auch mit der fahne
sozusagen in der schussrichtung stehe ja
wenn er sich verteidigen würde würde er
mich gezielt treffen aber ich weiß dass
er einfach mittlerweile so weit ist da
sagte ich akzeptiere das
[Musik]
blind vertrauen im wörtlichen sinne
müssen diese tiere denn sie werden in
heiklen situationen eingesetzt für
demonstrationen und fußballspielen die
polizeireiterstaffel wird angefragt um
randalierende fans zurückzudrängen oder
prügelnde ultras von anderen da zu
trennen wenn die kollegen unten hilfe
brauchen muss die reiterstaffel rang
bekommen wir dann in einer reiter kette
das heißt zu sechs zu 18 nebeneinander
auf einen haufen von 50 mann zu und
diese 50 man wissen ganz genau wenn die
polizeireiter sagen dienst fährt lauf
weiter dann laufen die auch weiter und
diese gewissheit dass die fußballfans
meistens dann in die bewegung bringen
ramin macht vor wie das geht wenn ich
jetzt nicht zurückweichen würde
sehen sie geht dieses pferd weiter
hooligans wissen womit man pferde
erschrecken kann
deswegen muss auch aventador den bengalo
test machen
er bleibt als letzter in der reihe
stoisch hause jetzt gibt es lob und
leckerli
nun soll rami no aus der ruhe gebracht
werden was nicht gelingt er ist durch
und durch polizei fährt die älteren
pferde nehmen meist die jungen in ihre
mitte um vorzumachen wie man in
unangenehmen situationen cool bleibt
polizeipferde lernen von anderen pferden
genauso viel wie durch ihren reiter kurz
bevor wir den auftrag bekommen wir es
einen platz zu räumen stehen die pferde
so da und in dieser position dieses
dichte enge gibt genau dieses herden
gefühl und in dieser herde sind sie
stark nächste übung ein schrecklich
lautes martin vorn
wieder sind es die älteren pferde die
den jüngeren zeigen wie man die ruhe
bewahrt
wer sind diese aventador hat heute alle
stresstest bestanden
ja auch ich war sehr positiv überrascht
und für mich hat er sich sehr souverän
gezeigt es zeigt einfach immer wieder
dass wenn er verunsichert ist dass er
sich trotzdem durch den reiter wieder in
die motivation bringen lässt und dann
zur ruhe kommt also top oder flop
eingekauft band adoro darf bleiben
unsere bald als polizei fährt seine
ersten aufregenden einsätze haben auf
ganz normale streife daher jetzt schon
gehen in den parks und auf den straßen
von frankfurt
polizeieinsatz in freiburg mit
sondersignalen heilen daniel stadt
ziehen ski und ralf setton mit zwei
polizeihunden im kofferraum durch die
stadt
die meldung in einer unterkunft für
flüchtlinge bedrohte ein mann einen
anderen mit einem messer eine
gefährliche lage hier muss petra die
schwarze schäferhündin von daniel starts
ins geäst ausgebildet für solche
vorkommnisse
wir müssen abstand halten können nur
mithören was sich in der unterkunft
abspielt in nur wenigen sekunden haben
pepper und daniel stadt in ski den
angreifer überwältigt es ging um ein
drogengeschäft der streit drohte zu
eskalieren
pepper hat die situation geklärt der
mann bleibt unverletzt
solche auseinandersetzungen beschäftigen
polizei und rettungsdienste immer wieder
aufs neue die hundestaffel der
freiburger polizei ist rund um die uhr
im einsatz
die person übergeben
die kollegen vom streifendienst und die
sind jetzt mit der weiteren ermittlungen
zu gange die müssen
personalia hebezeuge eventuellen tat war
versuchen wenn die eingesetzt wurde
wir sind jetzt einfach mit der
kompletten überarbeitung des
sachverhalts beauftragt zwei tage vorher
hundetraining rapper ist ausgebildet als
schutz und drogensucht und fünfeinhalb
jahre ist sie alt lebt zu hause mit
daniel stadt in ski in der freizeit
einstufe hund zeigt sie was sie kann
wenn jemand gewalttätig wird
[Musik]
fast alles richtig gemacht pepper hat
die situation gemeistert der ausbilder
ist zufrieden
da wurde aus spaß ernst weil die hunde
auch bei uns konditioniert werden
erfolgen angriff auf den hundeführer
sofort mit einer gegenwehr zu
beantworten und da hat man ja auch keine
zeit mehr muss der hund agieren muss der
hund vielleicht auch agiere wenn der
hundeführer gar nicht wahrnimmt
da sind angriff kommt wenn das
eigentlich kommt also da läuft ein
automatismus ab
in manchen nächten eilen die beamten der
polizei hundestaffel von einsatz zu
einsatz spezialaufträge wenn die
kollegen der reviere in freiburg und
umgebung vierbeinige unterstützung
anfordern
bei schlägereien bedrohungen
durchsuchungen und bei sprengstoffalarm
29 hunde und hundeführer arbeiten in
vier schichten 2016 haben sie fast 5000
einsätze meistern müssen
so wie auf diesem freiburger friedhof
anwohner haben hier hilfeschreie gehört
und über den notruf die polizei
verständigt die hunde bleiben vorerst im
wagen von jugendliche oder von einer
frau besser gesagt ob sich so ein
jugendliche streich hält handelt oder
nicht man keine personen angetroffen
auf dem friedhof ist es ruhig keine
besonderen vorkommnisse werden sie
später melden
viel zeit haben sie nicht sie müssen
weiter einsatz in titisee-neustadt 40
autominuten entfernt dort ist wepper in
einem drogen fall gefragt nach dem
messer an arm heißt es jetzt umschalten
nase einsetzen dafür wird erst einmal
das halsband gewechselt für den hund ist
das jetzt wie spielen wie im training
er hat ein breites band im schutzbereich
und für einen einsatz kriegt dann ein
enges dünnes über den kopf gezogen und
ist immer der gleiche ablauf seiten lang
und da rächt sich der hund einfach ein
verknüpftes anwender dann weißt dass du
nach honda jetzt wird viel gespielt
er war auch und so beispielsweise auf
training oder ernstfall der hund hat
spaß daran marihuana zu suchen
doch statt spielzeug sucht pepper jetzt
echte trugen wir müssen draußen bleiben
der hund wäre abgelenkt die kollegen vom
revier haben die wohnung bereits
durchsucht pepper macht jetzt die
feinarbeit von neustadt oder anrufe
laute musik offenes fenster haben die
kollegin klopft an der tür aufmacht und
typischer geruch marihuana dann hat man
staaten durch die staatsanwaltschaft in
der führungs befehl erwirkt und hat eine
anzug montage von tim einbauschrank in
einer einzimmerwohnung und jetzt sucht
man im raum steht und noch mal nach
eventuell und rechten wieder zurück nach
freiburg in eile ein neuer notruf der
sich aber als fehlalarm herausstellt das
heißt erst einmal entspannung für
polizisten und hunde rapper gibt sich
wieder ganz gelassen so muss es sein
aggression ist nur gefordert bei
tätlichen angriffen die wunder sind
einsatzmittel und in gewisser einsätze
braucht man die aggression von grundiert
an dem einsatz auch bringt wenn es darum
geht ein straftäter zum beide der sich
gegen uns widersetzt oder uns angreift
sind vielleicht die bilder die die leute
dann sehen wenn die runde weit
aufgerissene fang haben und mal die
große zähne kann dem ein oder anderen
vorkommen aber prinzipiell ische hund
ganz normales einsatzmittel und es wird
auch dringend benötigt
noch ein paar stunden nach dienst an
ausruhen ist nicht zu denken
der nächste einsatz steht schon an also
wir sind jetzt hier
dann kommt hier der notruf an wir sehen
die disponenten die quasi den bürger der
anruf direkt entgegen nehmen wie geht es
dann weiter weg und der polizei waren zu
dem einbrecher wichtig ist für uns erst
mal dass wir eben wo ist denn was
passiert und wir befindet sich in
welcher gefahrenlage in welchem straftat
bereich das machen die notruf
disponenten unterstützt durch einen
realen einsatz und unterstützungssystem
nennt sich zeus und das besagt dass wir
elektronisch daten erheben und diese
dann im einsatz sachbearbeiter funk
elektronisch zusteuert und heißt jetzt
das nun direkt mit den polizeistreifen
kommuniziert wird
das ist richtig wir sind aufgeteilt in
münchen in drei funkverkehrs kreise aus
west mitte jeweils mit zwei notruf und
funk disponenten besetzt die im
tagesmittel so zwischen 50 60 bis zu 80
90 einsatzmittel zeitgleich verwalten
jetzt regt mich auf wenn ich auf den
einwohner steht ein auto quer
ist das jetzt schon ein satz oder ist da
ist in einem tunnel ein verkehrsunfall
und jetzt könnte notos beamten
überprüfen ob sich da ein stau dadurch
entwickelt oder nicht was wir nicht
können was schön wäre ist dass wir mit
der kamera dann auch noch große
schwenkbewegungen vornehmen das können
wir nicht das sind die verkehrs kameras
auf die wir mal abschalten können aber
glücklicherweise haben wir so ein
bisschen im überblick wie sich das
verkehrsgeschehen
da entwickelt jetzt hat gesehen wie die
polizeiarbeit läuft bei einem
verkehrsunfall in einem tunnel auch
kritischer bereich aber wenn jetzt eine
richtig große einsatz wo zehn bis 15
streifenwagen verlangt werden wie läuft
das dann müssen sie vorstellen als er
ganz viele gleichzeitig zu machen einer
alleine kann das nicht machen so dass
man entsprechend strukturiert aufgeteilt
verständigungen zuführung von kräften
zuweisung von aufstellt örtlichkeiten
sammlung von kräften die zeit drei
aufträge erteilen es muss alles parallel
passieren kann sich nacheinander
passieren das läuft hier in der ersten
und in der folge phase dann die
entsprechend im führungsstab übergeben
der das dann übernimmt meinetwegen auf
präsidiums ebene dieses dann in die
folge phase führen
von hier aus werden im ernstfall auch
spezialkräfte wie die gsg 9 der
bundespolizei koordiniert mit einem
klassischen streifenpolizisten haben die
hochgerüsteten einsatzkräfte nichts mehr
gemein
sie haben waffen wie sie auch in
kriegseinsätzen gebraucht werden
schutzwesten und helme die von
projektilen aus kalaschnikows kaum
durchschlagen werden können vor ein paar
tagen die gsg9 trainiert für den
ernstfall
die spezialeinheit der bundespolizei ist
für den einsatz bei terrorangriffen und
geiselnahmen ausgerüstet trainiert und
auch psychologisch geschult
die beamten müssten im schlimmsten fall
um menschenleben zu retten
terroristen töten ohne jede vorwarnung
zu allem entschlossene täter die
letztendlich alles nutzen was ihnen an
an waffen an sprengmitteln zur verfügung
steht
da bis zum äußersten gehen und auch
nicht das interesse haben ja lebend aus
einer solchen situation rauszukommen und
das fordert natürlich auf unserer seite
auch absolut entschlossenes vorgehen
gegen gegen solche täter auch ihre waffe
wäre das letzte mittel um terroristen zu
stoppen bei selbstmordattentätern sogar
das einzige das wissen die
bundespolizisten am flughafen düsseldorf
aber ihre schutzwesten können von
kalaschnikows munition durchschlagen
werden sie haben weder die ausrüstung
noch das training einer spezialeinheit
über die gefahr für sie selbst reden sie
häufig miteinander
allein dass man selber sich
sensibilisiert dass man aktiver auch
dann ist und gemeinsam das gleiche ziel
verfolgt und die leute anspricht um
sowas zu
die beamten müssen den
sekundenbruchteilen entscheiden wer ein
terrorist sein könnte und wer nur ein
tourist wie dieser das drückt natürlich
auf ein höheres risiko für den beamten
eine andere herangehensweise und auch
ein mentales vorbereiten auf solche
laden weil das ist natürlich eine hohen
selbstgefährdung aussetzen deshalb
müssten sicherheitskräfte notfalls ohne
zögern auch verletzte täter töten in
istanbul schoss ein polizist einen
terroristen nieder
dann sah den sprengstoffgürtel rief eine
warnung und lief weg statt den
selbstmordattentäter zu erschießen wie
es die polizeitaktik in solchen fällen
eigentlich vorsieht
doch die vorgabe terroristen und
amokläufer schnellst möglich
auszuschalten kann auch so n
kurz nach den bombenanschlägen von
london erschoss die polizei einen
brasilianer weil er vor den beamten weg
liegt so schaal dem mfs war kein
terrorist sein tod ein tragischer irrtum
um solche fehler zu verhindern müssten
deutsche streifenpolizisten im
anti-terror-kampf besser ausgebildet und
ausgerüstet werden aber in einigen
bundesländern scheitert das an leeren
kassen auch bessere schutzwesten
fehlanzeige bei der ausbildung will die
gsg9 jetzt helfen da wollen wir als gsg9
auch gerne unseren beitrag leisten und
und versuchen auch die kräfte besser
auszubilden zu unterstützen
wir gehen das an mit multiplikatoren
schulungen für terror szenarien sind
zwar die spezialeinheiten von bund und
ländern zuständig aber bis sie im
ernstfall eintreffen bleiben
streifenbeamte die erste
verteidigungslinie gegen terroristen
22 juli 2016 mit den schüssen von
münchen beginnt für die polizei ein
wettlauf gegen die zeit
es ist auch ein wettlauf um die
deutungshoheit was ist wirklich passiert
wie viele täter wie viele tatorte eine
stadt in panik
wir kämpfen gegen ängste und nichts ist
schwieriger als mit sachargumenten gegen
ängste und befürchtungen anzutreten
in dieser ganzen flut an horror
nachrichten zwischen wahrheit einbildung
und gezielten fake news hält die
münchner polizei auf twitter dagegen
[Musik]
täter opfer alle beteiligten parteien in
einem solchen konflikt sind präsent und
das nicht nur zu einem beliebigen
zeitpunkt sondern live ja zum zeitpunkt
des geschehens und das schafft schon
eine ganz große herausforderung an die
polizeiarbeit der münchner polizei ist
das in hervorragender weise gelungen
dieser herausforderung zu begegnen dass
sich polizeiarbeit immer intensiver um
das geschehen in den sozialen netzwerken
dreht ist schlicht ein muss sagen
experten facebook und twitter dürfe man
gerade in krisenzeiten nicht ignorieren
[Musik]
ob das ein amoklauf ist ob das ein
terroristischer anschlag ist oder
krawall im rahmen eines g20 gipfels
überall hier spekulieren die straftäter
auf die verbreitung in den sozialen
medien und die polizei hat daher die
aufgabe hier einerseits auf zur
aufklärung zu leisten hier gerüchte
bildung entgegen zu wirken aber eben
auch folge straftaten zu vermeiden
am 6 juli eskaliert in hamburg die
gewalt auf der burg come to hell
demonstration gegen den g20-gipfel
geraten demonstranten und
sicherheitskräften aneinander
die polizei informiert auch hier ist
aber nach ansicht von experten auch
konfliktpartei und inszeniert sich als
akteur
man sieht an diesem fall sehr deutlich
wie stark hier die polizei gewissermaßen
mit ihrer twitter arbeit in das
geschehen involviert ist und eingreift
und das ist nicht ganz unproblematische
situation weil man damit natürlich auch
ein stück weit dass das geschehen ganz
konkret in der situation steuert aber
möglicherweise eben auch selber durch
die ereignisse
gesteuert wird um die arbeit mit
facebook und twitter weiter zu
verbessern müsste mehr investiert werden
fordern fachleute unisono
beim münchner amoklauf zum beispiel
suchten tausende polizisten nach dem
schützen nur vier beamte mussten über
100.000 tweets bearbeiten
die ruhe bewahrt und münchen beruhigt
hat damals marcus gloria martinez
polizeioberrat und sprecher der polizei
münchen heute nacht hat er
führungsdienst zusammen mit eva robnik
polizeioberkommissar in die nacht hat
eigene gesetze
nichts ist vorhersehbar und ranghöchster
polizist im einsatz
markus der gloria martin
herr martinz ist ganz ungewohnt sie
jetzt hier richtig im einsatz zu haben
ist das für sie jetzt auch mal wieder
was besonderes das sind eigentlich eher
so die die momente die ich viel zu
selten habe weil auf der einen seite
ebenso ein haus zu dem präsidium münchen
die kommunikation zu verantworten es
sicherlich eine herausforderung und
spannend aber ich habe den beruf aber
natürlich mal aus anderen gründen
ergriffen und das ist so immer die
momente wo es einmal back to the roots
geht
was genau ist jetzt ihre funktion heute
das ganze hat natürlich einen etwas
kryptischen namen hvd höhere beamte vom
dienst
wir sind quasi außerhalb der bürozeiten
die oberste einsatz leitungsebene
ich bin heute wenn sie so wollen
einsatzmäßig so der endspielgegner für
jeden rechtsbrecher das sind so meine
persönliche ausflüge in die realität
wieder
keine chance diesen gerade das wird ein
problem und die realität holt ihn
schnell wieder ein stück vor
sein
new york ap
reagierte dann fahr weiter bevor er
selber zum verkehrshindernis talent
er hat er nochmal also wenn wir uns
jetzt auf die rolle nimmt
katz-und-maus-spiel nacht in münchen
der reagierte alles gut
oder
ja
warum sie den polizisten geworden ist
eine gute frage
ich glaube so als berufsanfänger hat man
ja noch so diese vorstellung streit
schlichten und leben retten
das idealistische
mittlerweile muss ich sagen ich kann mir
keinen anderen beruf vorstellen weil es
einfach ein wahnsinnig
abwechslungsreiches und es darum also
für mich der polizei gerufen waren sie
in den schönen beruf ist aber nun sehr
faire soziale berufe als man oft
vergisst es gibt tatsächlich auch
situationen wo wertschätzung kommt und
wo man auch erlebt dass sie authentisch
ist wenn es einfach nur die alte oma ist
die vorbeikommt und abends ein pfund
kaffee auf die wache bringt und man
genau weiß da wo die wohnt da wohnt
nicht viel geld das ist teilweise mehr
wert als jedes dankschreiben von
irgendeiner hochdotierten persönlichkeit
durch diesen tiefen ist man da jetzt
flexibler und schneller in der lage
entscheidungen zu treffen
ja unbedingt die erfahrung zeigt einfach
dass wenn ein einsatz groß wird und
komplexe koordinierungsbedarf die ersten
30 bis 60 minuten absolut
erfolgsentscheidend für auch den gesamt
gesamten weiteren einsatzverlauf sind
wenn da nicht die die grundlagen gelegt
sind für eine vernünftige struktur und
für die einteilung der richtigen
fähigkeiten in die richtigen bereiche
dann kriegen sie das eigentlich im
späteren verlauf des einsatzes nicht
mehr eingefangen und diese schnelligkeit
der hat uns in den letzten jahren
tatsächlich relativ häufig schon den
entscheidenden zeitvorteil und in
einsatzlagen gebracht er meint ist das
hört sich ja auch alles ganz gut an wie
es in münchen läuft aber das
polizeiaufgaben sitzt wird ja nun auch
stark kritisiert wie kann man denn
verhindern dass es eben
missbräuchlich eingesetzt wird da wird
vieles was tatsächlich polizeiarbeit im
jahre 2019 zeitgemäß macht nämlich die
notwendigkeit des gesetzes grundlagen
auf der zunehmenden digitalisierung
gerecht werden im gleichen topf geworfen
wie zweifel zum beispiel an
rechtsbegriffen wieder drohnen gefahr
und da muss man dann auch als polizei
hingehen und erklären
man darf jetzt nicht einfach
unterstellen dass nur weil der
gesetzgeber sagt krone gefahr muss so
sein dass das sofort und widersprochen
tatsächlich von allen übernommen wird
man muss man muss hintergründe erklären
man muss tatsächlich auch an vielen
fällen klar machen warum wir in der
vergangenheit rechtlich an in den
grauzonen bis hin zu grenzen gekommen
sind obwohl ein handeln notwendig
gewesen wäre
aber eins zeigt die diskussion zu dem
thema auch der staat muss vielmehr
erklären warum dinge denn tatsächlich
notwendig sind und es keine staatliche
willkür ist sondern tatsächlich ein
versuch polizeiliche arbeit auch
zukunftsfähig zu machen und an arbeit
mangelt es der polizei nicht
trotz rückläufiger
kriminalitätsstatistik es kommen unter
dem strich zwar immer weniger anzeigen
oder oder
wirklich intervention pflichtige
straftaten aber dafür immer mehr
einsätze und was sie zum beispiel
bemerken ist dass die konfliktfähigkeit
der menschen abnimmt
während sie früher hat sondern zum
nachbarn gegangen sind wenn der die
musik zu laut hatte rufen sie heute die
notrufe an
wir sind mittlerweile der problemlöser
für ganz viele konflikte wo man einfach
wissen wir miteinander reden müsste und
die vor allem nicht zu die polizei sind
nichtsdestotrotz wenn wir gerufen werden
müssen wir da hin
und das ist einfach so dinge die
natürlich mit einer erwachsenen statt
auch zunehmend personal situation
allgemein sind sie da jetzt hier große
ketten für münchen sprechen aufgestellt
haben sie genug personal sind sie
zufrieden mit den aufstockungen oder
darf es noch ein bisschen mehr also in
bayern haben wir natürlich den vorteil
dass wir nie wirklich kürzungen hatten
der personalstand in bayern ist
mindestens immer gehalten worden wenn
sogar auch wenn nicht sogar leicht
ausgebaut worden
also insofern geht es uns dass er sehr
gut und wir haben noch einen großen
vorteil wir haben bewerberzahlen in die
teilweise im bereich von 1 zu 7 1 zu 8
sind das heißt also sieben acht bewerber
auf eine freie stelle und das ermöglicht
natürlich dann auch ich sage man sich
unter den bewerbern die rauszusuchen die
tatsächlich dieses aufgaben und
stellenprofil erfüllen die nacht ist
ruhig auch die streife zu fuß gehört zum
führungsteam
die bahnhofsgegend lockt die überall in
der welt nicht nur nachtschwärmer
doch heute ist die lage entspannt keine
beleidigungen keine betrügereien keine
gewalt in analogen welt die bahnhöfe der
zukunft das internet und das bringt
probleme mit sich
welche rolle spielt denn high tech
ausrüstung man merkt überall wird
digitalisiert wie ist das bei der
polizei jetzt im nächsten jahrhundert
also das thema cyber wird immer
wichtiger für uns das möchten wir zum
einen daran dass mittlerweile klassische
straftaten wie zum beispiel die
beleidigung die früher auf offener
straße ausgetauscht wurde einfach sich
in den digitalen raum verlagert
betrugsdelikte verlagern sich im
digitalen raum
es gibt kriminalitätsform die gibt es
nur wegen des digitalen raums und da
müssen wir natürlich als polizei schauen
dass wir mit fachlichkeit und
spezialisten dran bleiben weil der
digitalen raum
weicht vor allen dingen eins auf was für
uns das würde ganz wichtig ist dass das
territorialprinzip haben mittlerweile
das problem dass unser täter nicht im
nachbarort wohnt sondern dass der
betroffene server der möglicherweise
kriminelle oder inkriminierte inhalte
hat vielleicht eben nicht europäischen
ausland steht oder in einem staat steht
mit dem er kein rechtshilfeabkommen
haben trotzdem müssen wir was tun und
die fähigkeiten hier entsprechend
weitermachen zu können und nicht vor so
einer glas mauer zu scheitern ist
natürlich eine der großen
herausforderung
ganz ohne hightech im grunde ein ganz
altes handwerk hält die polizei in köln
auftrag taschendiebstahl der
hauptbahnhof in köln gilt als der
hotspot für taschendiebe in deutschland
die bundespolizei ist hier rund um die
uhr im einsatz
ich habe gerade gesehen dass ihre tasche
offen haben am besten möglichst nah am
körper tragen mit ihren gut gemeinten
ratschlägen haben johanna hanke und
alexander haare vermutlich schon einige
reisende davor bewahrt zu
diebstahlsopfer zu werden
die reisen sind natürlich auch abgelenkt
suchen die gleise wo sie hinmüssen oder
kommen bei anderen müssen sie erstmal
orientieren und das nutzen die täter
natürlich gerne aus wie leicht es ist im
bahnhof beute zu machen demonstriert die
streife in der vorhalle wäre
polizeikommissarin hanka eine diebin
hätte der besitzer der tasche jetzt ein
problem hatten eigentlich gar keine
chance hinterher zu kommen
der täter wurde jetzt das schnell
greifen damit weglaufen und vielleicht
noch ein zweiter täter von der anderen
seite ablenken glück für den taschen
besitzer johanna handke ist keine
kriminelle sondern kommissarin
der mann bekommt sein gepäckstück zurück
auch in zügen suchen diebe gezielt nach
potenziellen opfern szenen aufgenommen
von einer überwachungskamera in einem
regionalexpress ein fahrgast schläft
tief und fest in einem vierer abteil
zwei junge diebe nutzen die situation
stöpseln das kopfhörerkabel ab der
besitzer bekommt von all dem nichts mit
ja da ist ja die ablenkung im grunde
genommen noch größer man ist im
tiefschlaf und stellt dann
nicht fest dass man berührt wird gerade
wenn man auch vielleicht alkohol
konsumiert hat sollte man nicht in den
zügen schlafen zumindest nicht wenn man
alleine ist und niemand hat der auf
einen aufpassen kann weil wir schon
häufig festgestellt haben dass gerade
diese situation von den tätern
ausgenutzt wird
können sie die handtasche nehmen wir
gehen darüber motto der bundespolizei am
hauptbahnhof präsenz zeigen dazu gehören
auch kontrollen verdächtiger personen
kriminelle sollen wissen man hält sie im
auge einer der männer ist wegen
taschendiebstahls vorbestraft bei der
durchsuchung stellt polizeikommissare
ein messer sicher waffen wie diese
dienen als werkzeuge solche messer oder
auch andere scharfe gegenstände können
auch dazu genutzt werden um die
handtasche schnell vorbeigehen an
zumindest anzusetzen damit sie dann beim
ziehen dann er entwendet oder stelle
entwendet werden kann oder beim rucksack
auf der rolltreppe in der gedränge
situation wird etwas aufgeschnitten und
dann kann das ganz einfach entnommen
werden ohne dass der besitzer dass davon
etwas mitbekommt diebesgut tragen die
männer kainz bei sich kein grund sie
weiter festzuhalten
für einen laien ist es unmöglich diebe
in der menschenmenge des bahnhofs zu
erkennen
es sei denn man hat wie die
bundespolizisten die verhaltensweisen
der langfinger genau studiert sie laufen
ohne ziel auf und ab schauen sich immer
wieder andere reisende an
so wie dieser junge mann können sie die
hände wetter aus den taschen lassen
während der kontrolle haben sie mein
ausweis für mich der 27-jährige sieht
harmlos aus doch der eindruck täuscht
er ist bekannt wegen diebstahls
erkennungsdienstlich behandelt wurden
wegen diebstahls rissbildung kürbis 61
mit einer person f doch das ist nicht
alles
bei der personen ab frage kommt heraus
die staatsanwaltschaft so zu wegen
sexueller belästigung
um welche straftat es konkret geht
wissen die beamten nicht die
staatsanwaltschaft würde den 27 jährigen
gern vor laden kennt aber seine aktuelle
wohnadresse nicht wenn sie sich nicht
darum kümmern dann
wenn sie bald ausgeschrieben zur
festnahme und dann nehmen wir sie das
nächste mal mit das wäre nicht so gut
für die beamten ist der einsatz damit
beendet die streife wird zur
unterstützung ihrer kollegen auf der
wache gebraucht zivilfahnder haben zwei
taschendiebe festgenommen
endstation arrestzelle
die männer sind in einem zug auf
beutetour gegangen die diebe ahnen nicht
dass ein team von zivilfahndern im
abteil sitzt der konnten beobachten wie
einer der täter die tür blockiert hat so
dass der zug nicht abfahren konnte und
der zweite täter der hat sich im zug
umgeschaut und dann letztendlich eine
tatgelegenheit genutzt und eine
handtasche geklaut hat sich hier um zwei
diebe gehandelt die zum beispiel am
31.12 schon mal aufgefallen sind weil
sie innerhalb von wenigen stunden eine
hohe anzahl an straftaten begangen haben
also auch diebstähle
allerdings waren die beiden personen nur
von der kamera auswertung bekannt das
heißt die kollegen wussten bisher nicht
um wen es sich handelt die beiden werden
jetzt vorläufig festgenommen
okay natürlich auch immer gerne
hochwertige elektronik netzteile akku
wenn der pass weg ist dann ist natürlich
auch die weiterreise weiß gefährdet weil
man den flieger da nicht nehmen kann und
dann jetzt extrem teuer
die wertsachen wird sich das
diebstahlopfer später auf der wache
abholen
die beamten scannen zur identität
ermittlung die fingerabdrücke beider
täter dabei kommt heraus dass sich einer
der männer wahrscheinlich unerlaubt in
deutschland aufhält
neben einem strafverfahren wegen
taschendiebstahls wird gegen die männer
noch wegen drogenbesitzes ermittelt
das marihuana hatten die diebe nämlich
in ihrem socken versteckt
das ist polizei im einsatz
mit der streifen polizei von großen
sünden bis kleinen schwächen
in der einsatzzentrale beginnt sie die
jagd auf große haie und kleine fische
die arbeit der polizei hat zu jeder
tageszeit viel schatten viel licht in
deutschland sind rund 260.000 beamtinnen
und beamten im einsatz
die jährlich zu millionen von einsätzen
und tatorten gerufen werden
es geht auf der einen seite darum
menschen zu helfen und auf der anderen
seite menschen von straftaten abzuhalten
bei vielen konflikten sitzen polizisten
zwischen den stühlen
oft fühlt sich mindestens eine partei
von der polizei ungerecht behandelt es
jedem recht machen unmöglich und recht
sprechen ist aufgabe der gericht keine
leichte aufgabe also für die polizei im
einsatz
[Musik]